This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《以防万一》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人披着一身铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就真的需要这么做，去听听吧。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以防万一》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你把这个特定的检测报告篡改了整整两次，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时震惊得脑子一片空白。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。这就是有电梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是T-W-O%在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we're tackling, I would say a very important question in our 20s and beyond. Am I actually in love or am I just attached? I think we often find ourselves,
相信你的闺蜜。在iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目。今天，我们要探讨一个我觉得在我们二十岁及以后非常重要的问题。我真的恋爱了，还是只是产生了依恋？我想我们经常发现自己，
entangled in relationships and sometimes unable to distinguish between the intoxication of infatuation, the closeness of emotional attachment, and of course identifying whether this is a love that lasts. Particularly in our 20s, I think a lot of our relationships take on this very sensational passion, this fire, this really, this need to rush into things head first without pausing to, consider do I actually even like this person? Do I see them in my future? Or do I just like the companionship? Do I just like how they make me feel? Knowing that distinction is so important. So you can actually make good decisions, actually choose the right people rather than whoever is there at the time, especially if you're someone like me who occasionally has to deliberately hold back,
深陷于各种关系中，有时无法区分迷恋的陶醉、情感依恋的亲密，当然，还要辨别这是否是一段能持久的爱情。特别是在我们的二十岁，我认为我们的许多关系都带有这种非常轰动的激情，这种火花，这种真正需要一头扎进去的冲动，甚至没有停下来思考：我其实真的喜欢这个人吗？我能在未来看到他吗？还是我只是喜欢陪伴？我只是喜欢他们带给我的感觉？明确这种区别非常重要。这样你才能做出正确的决定，真正选择对的人，而不是随便哪个当时在场的人，特别是如果你像我一样，偶尔需要刻意克制自己的人，
which I've gotten a lot better at in a lot of my relationships to prevent falling head over heels after only a handful of dates. I know it's such a common experience. But importantly, attachment and love are very, very different. We develop our first attachments very young, almost immediately after birth, with our parents or our caregivers because we instinctually need to be able to rely on others for protection. before we have even the cognitive or the emotional capacity to love, we can form attachments. They're very foundational and the conditions for their creation is quite simple. Proximity to the person in question, a sense of closeness and dependency. Love, on the other hand, is a lot more complex.
我在很多关系中在这方面已经取得了很大进步，以至于在仅仅约会几次后就能避免迅速坠入爱河。我知道这是一种非常普遍的体验。但重要的是，依恋和爱是非常非常不同的。我们很小的时候就会发展出我们的第一层依恋，几乎在出生后立即与我们的父母或照顾者建立，因为我们在本能上需要依靠他人来获得保护。甚至在我们具备去爱的认知或情感能力之前，我们就能形成依恋。它们非常基础，而其产生的条件很简单。与相关人员的亲近感、一种亲密感和依赖感。另一方面，爱则要复杂得多。
It involves a deeper level of trust, a vulnerability, of compatibility, and selflessness. It's not just about what we need from someone else, what security they can provide for us, but what we need in unison, what we need as a pair. They feel alarmingly similar. I know that, especially if you've come to realize you've perhaps never been in love before. And attachment or emotional closeness is all you kind of have to base that feeling on. But today I really want to break down the difference. We are going to look at what.
它涉及更深层次的信任、脆弱性、契合度和无私。它不仅关乎我们需要别人什么，他们能为我们提供什么安全感，还关乎我们齐心协力需要什么，我们作为一对伴侣需要什么。它们感觉起来惊人地相似。我知道这一点，特别是如果你意识到自己可能从未谈过恋爱。而依恋或情感上的亲密是你唯一能用来作为这种感觉基础的东西。但今天我真的很想把这种区别剖析清楚。我们将探讨
love and attachment due to us at a very biological, rudimentary level, what function they each uniquely serve, and those cool ways to distinguish between the two feelings. We're also going to break down why some of us, myself included, get attached way too quickly, looking at things like anxious attachment styles, emotional validation, invariable reward, even models of addiction, as well as why it's important to try and stay single or prevent getting attached to people romantically during some of those big life changes that we go through in our 20s. And finally, how do we keep that emotional distance when we know we are people who attach very quickly or bond to others very quickly?
爱和依恋在非常生物学、初级层面上对我们产生的影响，它们各自独特发挥的功能，以及区分这两种感觉的那些绝妙方法。我们还将剖析为什么我们中的有些人（包括我自己）会这么快产生依恋，探讨诸如焦虑型依恋风格、情感确认、可变奖励、甚至是成瘾模型等内容，以及为什么在我们二十岁经历那些重大生活变化时，努力保持单身或避免与人产生浪漫依恋会如此重要。最后，当我们知道自己是那些非常容易对别人产生依恋或建立情感联结的人时，我们该如何保持这种情感距离？
How do we make it so that we let love develop slowly rather than confusing our attachment for something deeper? How can we de-center our love interests from our lives until they prove they deserve to be there? Well, I have a few answers for you, along with a lot of fascinating research and psychology behind this distinction. So I'm really excited for this episode. There is so much to cover. I know it is such a common conundrum. And I think it's really important that we set the record straight on the difference between these two experiences. Is it love or am I just attached? So without further ado, let us dive in. I know I mentioned it before
我们如何才能让爱缓慢发展，而不是把依恋误认为更深厚的东西？在我们证明他们值得拥有之前，我们如何将我们的爱慕对象从生活的中心移开？好吧，我有一些答案要分享给你，还有关于这种区别的大量迷人研究和心理学知识。所以我对这一期节目感到非常兴奋。有太多内容要涵盖了。我知道这是一个非常普遍的难题。而且我认为澄清这两种经历之间的区别真的很重要。是爱，还是我只是产生了依恋？所以话不多说，让我们深入探讨吧。我知道我之前提到过
and I don't know about you, but I have a massive tendency to, I think, attach very quickly to the people that come into my life, not just romantic, but also with friends or even people like work colleagues. I'm very much like an all or nothing kind of person. But often what that leaves me wondering, particularly in relationships, is whether I am truly in love with that person or I've just become accustomed to their companionship or I'm being driven by something more shallow, like obsession or lust or the basic principles of attachment. And I think discerning those two feelings is a really important part of our emotional toolkit. They may feel the same, but they have very different implications for the quality of our relationships. I always,
我不知道你怎么样，但我有一个巨大的倾向，就是我认为会对自己生活中出现的人迅速产生依恋，不仅是浪漫关系，还有朋友，甚至像工作同事这样的人。我非常像那种非黑即白的人。但通常这让我感到疑惑，特别是在恋爱关系中，我究竟是真正爱上了那个人，还是只是习惯了他们的陪伴，亦或是被某种更浅显的东西所驱动，比如痴迷、色欲或依恋的基本原则。我认为辨别这两种感觉是我们情感工具箱中非常重要的一部分。它们可能感觉起来一样，但对我们关系的质量有着截然不同的影响。我总是
think knowing the difference saves us from a lot of pain. I always use the example of situationships to explain this. Situationships, of course, are these relationships that feel legitimate and intimate and romantic or exclusive, but they're not. And typically, one person is invested and the other person is quite distanced. Now, because I am a hopeless romantic, I think I've always been that person who was wanted more. And sometimes in those situations, what I've realized in hindsight is that what I thought was love, what I thought was this deep bond I had to this person, was really just a very natural psychological and physical reaction to the emotional environment that that relationship had created. When you spend time with someone doing things that create a sense
认为知道其中的区别能让我们免受很多痛苦。我总是用“情缘难定”（situationships）的例子来解释这一点。情缘难定，当然就是那种感觉合法、亲密、浪漫或排他，但实际上并非如此的关系。通常，一个人投入了感情，而另一个人则相当疏离。现在，因为我是一个无可救药的浪漫主义者，我想我一直都是那个想要更多的人。有时在那些情况下，我事后意识到，我以为是爱的、我以为我和这个人之间建立的这种深厚纽带，实际上只是那种关系所营造的情感环境带来的一种非常自然的心理和生理反应。当你花时间与某人做一些能创造
of connection and release primarily hormones and neurotransmitters like oxytocin, things like going on dates and cuddles and sleeping next to each other and shared memories. All of these things create the neurological premise for bonding, which in turn causes an attachment to develop. And from that, perhaps love, but perhaps not, because it doesn't always get to that stage. So I want to explain the key differences between those two experiences. Let's start with love, particularly of the romantic sort. in the sequence of how a relationship develops, often it follows the pattern of lost, attraction, and then love. That's kind of the final stage when you've passed basic physical
连接感的事情，主要释放催产素等荷尔蒙和神经递质，比如约会、拥抱、睡在彼此旁边和共同的回忆。所有这些事情都为建立联结创造了神经学前提，进而导致依恋的发展。并由此可能产生爱，但也可能不会，因为它并不总是能发展到那个阶段。所以我想解释这两种经历之间的关键区别。让我们从爱开始，特别是浪漫的那种。在关系发展的序列中，通常遵循迷恋、吸引，然后是爱的模式。这可以说是当你超越了基础的生理
appeal and those urges. And you've really met someone beyond the surface level. I think maybe past that is perhaps a sense of comfortability. Now, the psychology behind love is really fascinating because it's perhaps one of the most intense emotions we can feel as humans, probably only second or even probably first compared to grief and things like anger. So for a long time, people have really wanted to know how it works. Why on earth does this feeling drive us to do wild things to create masterpieces and music to kill to start wars? And they've approached it from a few ways. From a biological perspective, this idea. They're saying, that love is no more than a bunch of neurotransmitters, serotonin, dopamine, oxytocin, that is doing things to our brain.
吸引和那些冲动之后的最终阶段。并且你真正了解了一个超越表层的人。我想这可能已经超越了那种舒适感。现在，爱背后的心理学真的很迷人，因为这可能是作为人类我们能感受到的最强烈的情感之一，可能仅次于甚至与悲伤和愤怒等情绪不相上下。所以在很长一段时间里，人们真的很想知道它是如何运作的。为什么这种感觉会驱使我们做疯狂的事情，去创作杰作和音乐，去杀戮，去挑起战争？他们从几个方面进行了探讨。从生物学的角度来看，这种观点。他们说，爱不过是一堆神经递质——血清素、多巴胺、催产素——在对我们的大脑做着某些事情。
They've also offered a social perspective that love serves an evolutionary purpose because it's needed to build community and social cohesion. But my favorite theory is called the triangular theory of love. And it's this integrated idea and what love is and what it isn't. This was developed a little while ago and the premise is that love, romantic love, true love is made up of three components, intimacy, passion, and commitment. Each point on this triangle needs to be fulfilled to say that love exists. If you like one of these things and we're specifically talking about romantic relationships here, you have something that isn't quite love. Without the commitment, you have a situation ship, Without the passion, you have something that might be very sexual or lustful without the intimacy.
他们还提出了一个社会学视角的解释，认为爱具有演化上的目的，因为它是建立社群和社会凝聚力所必需的。但我最喜欢的理论被称为爱的三角理论。这是一个关于什么是爱以及什么不是爱的综合理念。这个理论提出有一段时间了，其前提是爱，浪漫的爱，真爱由三个成分组成：亲密感、激情和承诺。三角上的每一个点都需要得到满足，才能说爱是存在的。如果你喜欢其中某一样东西——我们这里具体指的是恋爱关系——你就拥有了一种并不完全是爱的东西。如果没有承诺，你就是一段“情缘难定”，如果没有激情，你拥有的东西可能非常具性吸引力或充满色欲，而缺乏亲密感。
And without the intimacy, you have a friendship. Now, intimacy encompasses feelings of attachment. But beyond that, it's also, you know, including things like trust, like security, vulnerability, you know, sensations that go way beyond a simple closeness or biological bond. love also follows what some have proposed as a fairly typical pattern. So a group of researchers have proposed almost a four-stage model to love. You start off in the euphoric stage, which is around six months to two years, then early attachment one to five years, followed by the crisis stage, where perhaps we begin to drift apart or wonder whether this is really what we want.
而如果没有亲密感，你拥有的就只是一段友谊。现在，亲密感包含着依恋的感觉。但除此之外，它还包括（你知道的）诸如信任、安全感、脆弱性等东西，（你知道的）那些远远超出简单亲密感或生物学联结的感觉。爱也遵循一些人所提出的相当典型的模式。因此，一组研究人员提出了关于爱的四阶段模型。你从大约六个月到两年的欣快阶段开始，然后是为期一到五年的早期依恋，接着是危机阶段——大约在五到七年时，我们可能开始渐行渐远，或者怀疑这是否真的是我们想要的，
is this really working out at around five to seven years? And finally, the deep attachment, the deep knowing around seven years and beyond. I actually think from an observational standpoint, this makes a lot of sense in my own experience, seeing a lot of those people I've known who have been together around that five year point, really observing how their relationships shift to another level, all they fall apart entirely. You know, there is no consensus on what love is because there are more spiritual conceptions that might call it fate or they might say it's something deeply entwined with the universe and our soul. There is so much, I think, very deep human sentiment attached to this feeling. But I think really what it is is a deeply powerful
这真的行得通吗？最后是大约七年及以后的深度依恋、深度了解。我实际上认为，从观察的角度来看，这在我的自身经历中很有道理，我看到很多我认识的人在走到大约五年这个节点时，真正观察到他们的关系如何转变到另一个层面，或者彻底破裂。你知道，对于什么是爱并没有共识，因为还有更精神层面的概念，可能会称之为命运，或者他们会说那是与宇宙和我们的灵魂深度交织的东西。我认为有太多非常深刻的人类情感依附于这种感觉。但我真正认为它是一种极其强大的
connection that is built on the back of a lot of seemingly minuscule things, things that we overlook. Communication, memories, shared values, deep intimacy, passion, but also compassion, seeing the world through the eyes of another, knowing that they are just as much a part of your life as you are a part of your life. Being in love and desiring the love of others can be one of the strongest motivators in our life. if we approach it correctly, and if we are able to discern when perhaps it's something maybe less significant. So let's talk about attachment.
连接，建立在许多看似微不足道的事情的背后的连接，那些我们忽视的事情。沟通、回忆、共同的价值观、深刻的亲密感、激情，还有同情心，通过另一个人的眼睛看世界，知道他们和你一样是你生活的一部分。身处爱中并渴望得到他人的爱可以成为我们生活中最强大的动力之一。如果我们以正确的方式对待它，如果我们能够辨别什么时候它可能是一种不那么重大的事情。所以我们来谈谈依恋。
I think intuitively, we know it's probably a rung or two below that all-consuming sensation that we were just describing. It's really interesting because if you ask people if they've ever been in love, especially in our 20s, I hear this response all the time. I think I thought I was at the time, and now I'm not sure. I thought I was in love. And what they're probably speaking to was actually attachment. So attachment is defined as a lasting psychological connectedness between human beings. And most of what we know comes from the work of John Bulby. He is a very well-known psychiatrist. If you study psychology, you definitely would have heard about him.
我认为凭直觉，我们知道它可能比我们刚才描述的那种吞噬一切的感觉要低上一两级。这真的很有趣，因为如果你问人们是否曾经谈过恋爱，特别是在我们二十岁的时候，我经常听到这样的回答。我想我当时以为是的，现在我不敢确定了。我以为我恋爱了。而他们所说的可能实际上是依恋。因此，依恋被定义为人类之间持久的心理连结。而我们所了解的大部分内容来自于约翰·鲍比（John Bulby）的工作。他是一位非常著名的精神病学家。如果你学过心理学，你绝对听说过他。
and he was particularly interested in working with what he called at the time emotionally disturbed children. Our first attachment is to our parents or our caregivers, and it basically occurs from birth. We are biologically, genetically, evolutionarily, pre-programmed to form attachments, particularly with the people who care for us or give us attention, and those who are around us frequently. and we can form these attachments well before we have any of the necessary cognitive or emotional functions to feel love. Attachment is based on who is fulfilling our needs, who is consistent in our lives and who can create that very much needed sense of security. This is really necessary for our survival because, you know, we needed to be able to identify who is going to protect us back when I think,
他特别对与他当时所称的“情绪受损儿童”一起工作感兴趣。我们的第一层依恋是针对我们的父母或照顾者的，它基本上从出生起就发生了。我们在生物学上、基因上、演化上都被预先编程来形成依恋，特别是与那些照顾我们、给我们关注的人，以及那些经常在我们身边的人形成依恋。并且我们可以在拥有任何去爱所需的认知或情感功能之前很久就形成这些依恋。依恋的基础是谁在满足我们的需求，谁在我们生活中始终如一，谁能创造那种非常需要的安全感。这对于我们的生存绝对是必要的，因为，你知道的，我们需要能够识别谁会保护我们，回想起来，
things are a lot more perilous. And I think that it's also quite a basic foundational relationship. The one we have with our parents is going to greatly influence how we approach that broader idea of love. And I think we need to briefly talk about attachment theory here. Attachment theory has definitely been doing the rounds. It's one of those psychological theories that has mass appeal in mainstream media because it really claims to predict how you love and proposes an explanation for all of your perhaps love conundrums. So a brief synopsis, this model proposes that there are four attachment styles that humans can have.
事情要危险得多。而且我认为这也是一段非常基础的关系。我们与父母的关系将极大地影响我们对待更广泛的爱的方式。我想我们在这里需要简短地谈谈依恋理论。依恋理论绝对一直在流行。它是那种在主流媒体中具有广泛吸引力的心理学理论之一，因为它确实声称能够预测你的恋爱方式，并为你的所有恋爱难题提供解释。所以简短的梗概是，这个模型提出人类可以有四种依恋风格。
And these attachment styles are derived primarily from the relationship that we had with our parents and the care and the love they showed us. And how that relationship and attachment to them has developed will then serve as our first image of how we should connect with people later on in our lives, especially in adulthood. So the four styles are secure. These are people who are confident, resilient, non-reactive, reciprocal, especially in their relationships. And they don't really display anxiety when approaching things like romance or commitment or even harder feelings like rejection. Next, we have anxious preoccupied. This is characterized by a deep fear of abandonment.
而这些依恋风格主要源于我们与父母的关系，以及他们向我们表现出的关怀和爱。这种关系以及对他们的依恋如何发展，将随后成为我们日后与人建立连接的最初形象，特别是在成年期。所以这四种风格是：安全型。这些人自信、有韧性、不敏感、互惠，特别是在他们的恋爱关系中。而且他们在面对浪漫、承诺甚至是诸如拒绝等更艰难的情感时，并不会表现出真正的焦虑。接下来，我们有焦虑沉迷型（anxious preoccupied）。这以对被抛弃的深切恐惧为特征，
high levels of insecurity, perhaps really what we would say is clingy behavior and also a level of fantasy bonding. And this attachment style is really important when we talk about this distinction between love and attachment. So remember it because we will come back to it later. But thirdly, we have dismissive, avoidant, these individuals will often stay quite emotionally distant. They isolate themselves, maybe reject attempts from others at deep emotional connection. And I think it's often because they've been taught from very, very early childhood that they can't trust people who promise to care for them. So they push them away because they've associated deep connection with being hurt. And then finally we have fearful avoidant,
高度的不安全感，也许正如我们所说的黏人行为，以及一定水平的幻想绑定（fantasy bonding）。这种依恋风格在我们讨论爱与依恋的区别时非常重要。所以请记住它，因为我们稍后会回到这一点。但第三，我们有疏离回避型（dismissive avoidant），这类个体通常会保持相当的情感距离。他们孤立自己，可能会拒绝其他人建立深厚情感连接的尝试。我认为这通常是因为他们在极早的童年就被教导，他们不能信任那些承诺照顾他们的人。所以他们把人推开，因为他们把深厚的连接与受伤联系在了一起。然后最后我们有恐惧回避型（fearful avoidant），
dismissive avoidant and fearful avoidant are somehow or sometimes just kind of rolled into one as just an avoidant, a blanket avoidant attachment. But the fearful avoidant can come as both very ambivalent but also very unpredictable. And whilst the dismissive avoidant may just completely switch off, the fearful avoidant may create conflict in their relationships to try and push people away and see if they'll leave, as others have done, because they really can't fully trust them. They're constantly testing this relationship for weak spots.
疏离回避型和恐惧回避型有时会被笼统地合称为一种回避型，即一种全盘的回避型依恋。但恐惧回避型既可能表现得非常矛盾，也可能非常不可预测。疏离回避型可能会完全关闭自己，而恐惧回避型可能会在他们的关系中制造冲突，试图把人推开，看看对方会不会像其他人以前那样离开，因为他们真的无法完全信任对方。他们不断地考验这段关系中的薄弱环节。
Now, these unique attachment styles will influence how are your approach love and dating, but they are the basis also for seeking out intimacy. I think the easiest way to distinguish love versus attachment is that you can be attached to someone and not love them, but in order to love someone, you have to be attached. I want to talk about some of the other ways that we can distinguish between these two things, because like I said before, and if you have had past experience, you'll know they feel very, very similar. I also think that when we confuse them, we can use what we think is love as reasoning to do things that might not be in our best interest, like moving in with someone after only a few months, or ignoring other possible people
现在，这些独特的依恋风格将影响你如何对待爱和约会，但它们也是寻求亲密感的基础。我认为区分爱与依恋最简单的方法是，你可以对一个人产生依恋却不爱他们，但为了爱一个人，你必须产生依恋。我想谈谈我们区分这两者的其他一些方式，因为就像我之前说的，如果你有过过去的经历，你就会知道它们感觉起来非常非常相似。我也认为，当我们把它们混淆时，我们可能会把我们自以为是爱的感觉作为理由去做那些可能不符合我们最佳利益的事情，比如仅仅几个月后就和某人同居，或者忽视其他可能的人选
or options or red flags. So I think both of them feel like a sense of security, both make us feel close to another person. But whilst love is selfless, attachment is. somewhat selfish. Whilst love is very mutual, importantly, attachment can be one-sided and quite transient. So when I say attachment is selfish, I don't mean that that makes you a selfish person because we all have some basic level of attachment, just that the function of attachment is self-serving. For example, when we consider the early stages of dating, when we are forming this bond with someone, what we're really looking at is, what is this person doing for me? Is this person making me happy? What feelings are they creating for me? How do I feel? Rather than
或选项或危险信号（red flags）。所以我认为这两者都带有一种安全感，都能让我们觉得与另一个人很亲近。但爱是无私的，而依恋却。某种程度上是自私的。爱是非常相互的，重要的是，依恋可能是单方面的，而且相当短暂。所以当我说依恋是自私的时，我并不是说这让你成了一个自私的人，因为我们所有人都有某种基准水平的依恋，只是依恋的功能是自我服务的。例如，当我们考虑约会的早期阶段，当我们与某人建立这种羁绊时，我们真正关注的是：这个人对我做了什么？这个人让我开心吗？他们为我创造了什么感觉？我的感觉如何？而不是
what can I do to make them happy? How can we grow together? How can I love them better? Attachment is really driven by how you feel about yourself. How, if you feel secure and the safety and attention someone gives you based on all of these different models. A big part of attachment is that it's highly subjective and it can be really easily influenced by our own visions or interpretations of what this person is offering and it can also feel incredibly intense because biologically our brains want us to attach to others so it makes us fairly susceptible to ignoring things like red flags for the momentary, physical, emotional, mental comfort that someone may offer us. Also, getting incredibly attached to someone isn't always based on what they're actually
我能做些什么让他们开心？我们如何才能共同成长？我该如何更好地爱他们？依恋实际上是由你对自己的感觉所驱动的。基于所有这些不同的模型，你是否感到安全，以及别人给予的安全感和关注度如何。依恋很大一部分在于它具有高度的主观性，它很容易受到我们自己对这个人所提供东西的愿景或解释的影响，而且它还会让人感到难以置信的强烈，因为在生物学上，我们的大脑希望我们依附于他人，所以它让我们相当容易忽视诸如危险信号之类的东西，只为了某人可能提供给我们的短暂、生理、情感、精神上的舒适。此外，对某人产生极度依恋并不总是基于他们实际
showing you or their actions, but sometimes the fantasy that we've created of them in our own heads. It's this concept called fantasy bonding, and it occurs when you bond and attach to someone based on who you believe they can be or will be or will be. what you believe they can and will be able to give you in the future, not who they actually are. When you have a fantasy bond with someone, you often are in a very dysfunctional,
展现给你的东西或他们的行动，有时是我们自己在脑海中对他们创造的幻想。这是一个叫做“幻想绑定”的概念，当你在脑海中相信某人可以成为、将会成为或将能够成为什么样的人时，你就会与这样的人建立羁绊和依恋，你是根据你相信他们未来能够给予你的东西来建立羁绊，而不是根据他们实际是谁。当你与某人有幻想绑定时，你通常处于一个非常功能失调的、
I would say situation or relationship where you have created a false image of them in your head, or you've looked to the future to justify why you feel so close to them and to psychologically protect yourself. You're not always in love with someone, you're in love with the idea of love or the idea of them. And I think in contrast to that, love is very honest. It's sometimes brutally honest.
我要说的是，那种你在脑海中为他们创造了一个虚假形象，或者为了让自己感觉和他们如此亲近以及在心理上保护自己而寄希望于未来的一种情况或关系。你并不总是爱着某人，你爱的是爱的概念或是关于他们的概念。我想与此相反的是，爱是非常诚实的。有时它是残酷地诚实。
I truly believe that you can't love someone until you've seen something about them that you don't like. Or you've had some disagreement or you've seen them angry. You've seen them vulnerable. And you have still chosen to be there. You don't have unrealistic expectations about who they are or what they could be. you just kind of take them as they are, whereas in attachment, you're very willing to overlook those things for what they can give you. Additionally, I think love is mutual. Attachment can be one-sided, wherein one person has really developed a bond and a connection, perhaps based on
我坚信，在你看到他们身上某些你不喜欢的地方之前，或者你们发生过一些争执，或者你看到他们生气之前，你是不可能真正爱一个人的。你见过他们脆弱的一面。而你依然选择留在那里。你对他们是谁或他们可能成为什么样的人没有不切实际的期望。你只是某种程度上接受他们本来的样子，而在依恋中，你非常愿意为了他们能给予你的东西而忽视这些事情。此外，我认为爱是相互的。依恋可能是单方面的，其中一个人真正发展出了一种羁绊和连接，也许是基于
false cues, and the other person can realistically remain very distant. You know, everyone has their own timelines for how long it takes to connect with others, but also in some instances, not all, but some people like being chased and they can breadcrum us with tiny moments that invariably reinforce our connection to them. It's this notion in psychology of invariable reward. It's the same way that casinos get people to gamble more. Sometimes this person will be super affectionate and kind and loving and that's where we feel like we have won the so-called jackpot. And other times, they'll be really distant or dismissive. And in those moments, we want to keep pushing.
虚假的线索，而另一个人实际上可以保持非常疏离。你知道，每个人都有自己与他人建立连接所需的时间表，但在某些情况下——不是全部，但有些人喜欢被追逐的感觉，他们会用微小的时刻像面包屑一样喂养我们，不断地强化我们与他们的连接。这就是心理学中的“可变奖励”概念。这和赌场让人沉迷赌博的方式是一样的。有时这个人会超级体贴、亲切、充满爱意，而那就是我们觉得自己中了所谓头奖的时候。而另一些时候，他们会非常疏离或冷漠。而在那些时刻，我们会想要继续推动。
We want to keep betting or gambling more because we are looking for the satisfaction of when they are once again giving us those warm feelings. We just don't know when that's going to happen. So whilst we may be attached, we may also be very much addicted to their inconsistent behavior and interpret that anxiety as excitement or even a deeper feeling of passion.
我们想要继续下注或赌更多，因为我们在寻找当他们再次给予我们那些温暖感觉时的满足感。我们只是不知道那什么时候会发生。所以虽然我们可能产生了依恋，但我们也可能非常沉迷于他们不稳定的行为，并将那种焦虑解释为兴奋，甚至是更深层次的激情。
I never knew what people meant when they say that love should be easy and consistent and feel safe because I always thought that what I wanted was intensity and passion and that sinking feeling in my stomach. That was, for me, true emotion. That was true feeling. That was love. But I think maturing is realizing that it's not. It's a very natural alarm system, a natural reaction to someone's inconsistency. and lack of stability and it creates almost a chronic stress response. It's very similar to infatuation, the all-consuming feeling that very quickly and intensely flourishes
我以前从来不知道人们说“爱应该是轻松、持续且让人感到安全的”是什么意思，因为我总是以为我想要的是强度、激情以及胃里那种下沉的感觉。对我来说，那是真正的感情。那是真实的感觉。那是爱。但我认为走向成熟就是意识到事实并非如此。这只是一种非常自然的警报系统，是对某人的不一致
at the beginning of a new relationship. It's the anxiety and the euphoria and the nervousness. And if that carries on for many, many months, it might be worth examining whether that is actually love, whether that is actually a good foundation for love, whether there is actually genuine friendship and care there, or whether someone is actually just using you to fulfill their own emotional hunger and emotional cravings.
和缺乏稳定性的一种自然反应，它几乎会产生一种慢性的压力反应。这与迷恋非常相似，那种在新恋情刚开始时非常迅速且强烈地蓬勃发展的、吞噬一切的感觉。那是焦虑、欣快感和紧张感。如果这种情况持续很多很多月，或许就值得检视这是否真的是爱，这是否真的是爱的良好基础，那里是否真的存在真正的友谊和关怀，或者是否有人其实只是在利用你来满足他们自己的情感饥饿和情感渴望。
One final debate or differentiation that I think we should discuss is that I really believe that you can be attached to multiple people at once, but I don't think that you can be in love with them all. Definitely not in the same way. Our minds and social brains have adapted to allow for us to have multiple, deep attachments with people like friends, like family. That's really the basis for community. But I think love is a lot more exclusive.
我认为我们应该讨论的最后一个辩论或区别是，我坚信你可以同时对多个人产生依恋，但我认为你不可能同时爱上所有人。绝对不可能用同样的方式。我们的思维和社交大脑已经适应了允许我们与诸如朋友、家人之类的人建立多重、深厚的依恋。那真的是社群的基础。但我认为爱要排他得多。
Obviously, you can love multiple people, but in a different sense to that deep, romantic, intimate love we're talking about. It takes so much from us emotionally, I think, but it also requires your deep attention to another person that's hard to cultivate with multiple people at the same. time and it's a lot harder I think to fall out of love compared to falling out of attachment. That's a really good thing about attachment depending on how you look at it, but especially for those of us who are maybe emotionally attached to someone in their lives right now who is maybe
显然你可以爱多个人，但那与我们所谈论的那种深厚的、浪漫的、亲密的情感是不同的概念。我认为它在情感上从我们这里索取了太多，而且它还需要你对另一个人付出极大的关注，这很难在同时对多个人时培养出来。而且与从依恋中抽离相比，我认为要“不再爱一个人”要难得多。这可以说是依恋的一个非常好的方面，这取决于你如何看待它，但特别是对于我们当中那些目前在生活中对某人产生了情感依恋，而这个人可能
not the best for us, but attachment is founded on proximity and frequency of interaction. When you take away that source, when you take that fuel away, when you apply distance, our attachment fades and I think it's a really great way to distinguish that because love will last a lot longer. Think about it in terms of people who sadly have lost a spouse or a partner. That takes years to heal from. In some ways I think we never heal or forget that love. So hopefully that has given you a good preliminary idea of the distinction. But what I want to talk about next is why some of us get attached a lot quicker than others, myself included, and also some questions. And also some questions to ask yourself when you're thinking, do I actually love this person or do I love
对我们并不是最好的，但依恋是建立在接近度和互动频率的基础上的。当你剥夺了那个源头，当你拿走那个燃料，当你引入距离时，我们的依恋就会消退，我认为这是一个极好的区分方法，因为爱会持久得多。试想一下那些不幸失去配偶或伴侣的人。从那样的伤痛中恢复需要数年时间。某种程度上，我认为我们永远无法真正治愈或忘记那种爱。所以希望这为你提供了一个很好的初步概念，让我们了解其中的区别。但我接下来要谈的是，为什么我们中的一些人比其他人更快地产生依恋，包括我自己，以及一些问题。当你思考“我真的爱这个人吗，还是我爱的是
the idea of them or do I love their companionship? And then finally, how do we actually detach ourselves when we realize we're in that situation, when we realize that this may be a temporary connection, how do we slow things down and let it develop over time? So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is only also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
他们的概念，或者我爱的是他们的陪伴”时，问自己的一些问题。然后最后，当我们意识到自己身处那种情况时，当我们意识到这可能只是一段临时连接时，我们究竟该如何让自己抽离出来？我们如何放慢节奏让它随时间发展？所有这些以及更多内容，将在短暂停顿后继续。2%。这就是当有电梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TW0% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
去审视那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier 的人。收听《2%》。也就是T-W-O%在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？还是当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客的节目，滔滔不绝地大谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Now you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我很乐意在白天谈论可卡因，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。我开始看出这其中有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。现在你把那句话说完了。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, month. I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we
是的。对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《以防万一》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月。我将把我十多年在心理健康领域的个人经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是。特里·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们
are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear. here on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join
已经拥有了那样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂芬·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入
me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2020 3, former Bachelor star
我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《以防万一》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用。搜索《以防万一》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星
Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. Family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你把这个特定的检测报告篡改了整整两次。我篡改了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时震惊得脑子一片空白。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It goes without saying that there are some of us out there who have a tendency to fall hard and fast to believe we are in love when really what might be happening is a very visceral, biological and emotional reaction to what you want someone else to be, your idea of them in your mind. If you find yourself utterly obsessed with someone after, you know, a couple of dates, already fantasizing about the wedding, telling all your friends, moving way too fast, or even find yourself, that you can jump from relationship to relationship incredibly easily and be met with that same level of infatuation every single time or if you know that deep down that you have this
随着节目继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。不用说，我们当中有些人确实有一种倾向，会陷得很深很快，会相信自己正在恋爱，而实际上可能发生的事情是对你希望别人成为什么样的人——你在脑海中对他们的概念——的一种非常直观、生物学和情感上的反应。如果你发现自己在经历了（你知道的）几次约会后就对某人彻底着迷，脑子里已经在幻想婚礼，告诉所有的朋友，进展太快，甚至发现自己可以极其轻松地从一段关系跳到另一段关系，并且每一次都遭遇同等程度的迷恋，或者如果你内心深处知道你有
destructive pattern and you ignore red flags this might be describing a subconscious and habitual tendency to emotionally attach to others and there are a few psychological reasons why that may occur firstly if you remember that anxious attachment style we discussed earlier, well, that is a massive contributor. The development of an anxious, sometimes it's called preoccupied attachment style, is often associated with an inconsistent parenting pattern. Sometimes people have parents who will be supportive and responsive to a child's emotional needs, and then at other times, they'll really neglect them and ignore them. And this inconsistency makes it really difficult for us as children to understand what we can expect from our parents
破坏性的模式，而你却忽视了危险信号，这可能描述了一种下意识且习惯性的情感依附倾向，背后有几个心理学原因。首先，如果你还记得我们之前讨论过的焦虑型依附风格，那么，它是一个巨大的推动因素。焦虑型（有时被称为专注型）依附风格的发展，通常与不一致的育儿模式有关。有时父母会对孩子的需求给予支持和回应，但有时又会真正地忽视和冷落他们。这种不一致让我们作为孩子时，很难理解能从父母那里期待什么
and what their behavior actually means. And so we end up confused about the relationship we have with these caregivers. And what happens is this expression called emotional hunger, where we crave the love of our parents. We are really anxious around them and when we can expect emotional fulfillment because it's never consistent. It's like never being fed on schedule when you. never given love on a schedule. So in adulthood, this manifests in a very intense fear of abandonment and a propensity to attach very quickly to those who show us even the most basic of human empathy
以及他们的行为到底意味着什么。因此，我们最终对与这些照顾者的关系感到困惑。随之而来的是一种叫做“情感饥饿”的表达，我们渴望父母的爱。我们在他们身边时会非常焦虑，不知道什么时候才能得到情感上的满足，因为这种满足从来都不是持续的。就像从不按时吃饭一样，你从来没有在固定的时间得到过爱。所以在成年后，这表现为对被抛弃的极度恐惧，以及迅速依附于那些向我们表现出哪怕是最基本的共情
and care and connection, like a new romantic interest. We become very, very obsessed with their presence and worried that they'll leave us. And this once again might reinforce that we don't deserve love. So instead, we go all in. We go as hard as possible because we want to seemingly protect ourselves from this outcome by giving this misconception, by creating this false narrative that if we commit quicker, if we attach quicker, it will be harder for them to leave us. And I think that can often backfire when we either overwhelm this person or we get to the point in a relationship, which all relationships face where we have to have hard conversations. We will have fights.
以及关怀和连接的人的倾向，比如一个新的浪漫对象。我们会变得非常非常沉迷于他们的存在，担心他们会离开我们。而这又一次可能会强化我们不配得到爱的想法。所以相反，我们会全力以赴。我们会竭尽全力，因为我们似乎想通过这种错误的认知、通过构建这样一个虚假叙事来保护自己免受这种结果的伤害：如果我们承诺得更快，如果我们依附得更快，他们就会更难离开我们。而我认为，这往往会适得其反，当我们让这个人感到窒息，或者我们到了关系中所有关系都要面对的时刻——我们必须进行艰难的对话。我们会争吵。
We will have disagreements or sometimes be let down. And when that happens, because our attachment to them has been based on this very fantasy-like image, this intensity, we will feel threatened because we have created an incredibly emotionally intense and at times fragile bond. It's not just childhood abandonment though, but also our early romantic experiences, things like a particularly devastating breakup or the end of a relationship. This can also teach us that we need to bond very quickly to hold on to people. This can also be created by repeated situationships or flings where we feel like things have really never reached that next level.
我们会产生分歧，或者有时会感到失望。而当这种情况发生时，由于我们对他们的依附是基于这种非常虚幻的形象、这种强度，我们会感到受到威胁，因为我们建立了一种极其情绪化、有时又很脆弱的纽带。但这不仅关乎童年被抛弃的经历，还关乎我们早期的恋爱经历，比如一次特别毁灭性的分手或一段关系的结束。这也可能教会我们，我们需要非常迅速地建立羁绊来留住人们。这也可以由反复的“友达以上”或短暂的恋情造成，在这些关系中，我们觉得事情似乎从未达到下一个阶段。
So we are constantly seeking out people who might do that. this for us who might fulfill this need and then in creating that internal delusion that we are in love because subconsciously that is what we would like to believe and so we make that a reality for ourselves in our imagination. This comes down to two other factors that I think are very interlinked. Firstly, you believe that a relationship or love or someone else will make you happy and that belief has emerged from a deeply rooted insecurity that maybe you're not good enough or you don't deserve the love that you're after. Other people are a huge source of emotional validation, especially if we are highly self-critical and haven't learned to trust our own opinions of ourselves. In those instances,
所以我们不断地寻找能够做到这一点的人。为我们寻找能够满足这种需求的人，然后在内心制造一种错觉，即我们已经恋爱了，因为潜意识里这就是我们想要相信的，于是我们在想象中让它成为了现实。归根结底，我认为这取决于另外两个相互紧密联系的因素。首先，你相信一段关系、爱或某个人会让你快乐，这种信念源于一种根深蒂固的不安全感，也许你觉得自己不够好，或者你不配得到你所追求的爱。其他人是情感确认的重要来源，尤其是如果我们高度自我批判，并且还没学会相信自己对自己的看法。在这些情况下，
we really need others to confirm that we are good, that we are attractive, that we are intelligent, that we are desirable. And when people offer that to us, even in small doses, This can cause us to attach much quicker because they have now become a really valuable source for our self-confidence, which is a very crucial psychological need. There's been studies on this and what they found is that people who rate their self-esteem as lower or poorly, they respond with greater emotional intensity to compliments, particularly from people they admire. So it's important to examine if this is the conditions of your current relationship, or the current early stages of a relationship,
我们真的很需要别人来确认我们是优秀的、有吸引力的、聪明的、有魅力的。当人们向我们提供这些时，哪怕是微不足道的剂量，这也可能导致我们更快地产生依附，因为他们现在已经成了我们自信心的宝贵来源，而自信心是一个非常关键的心理需求。关于这一点有过研究，研究发现，那些自评自尊心较低或较差的人，对赞美的反应具有更强的情绪强度，尤其是来自他们崇拜的人的赞美。所以检查一下这是否是你目前关系的状态，或者是一段关系早期的状态，这一点很重要，
whether this person is actually someone you're compatible with, if they are a good person who you trust, or if they're just giving you the validation or perhaps even companionship to counter your loneliness. Because loneliness is also something that can drive us to attach very quickly. Partners, boyfriends, girlfriends, love in general is a pretty powerful protective factor against loneliness. but if we use relationships as a band-aid solution or to feel some emotional void,
这个人是否真的是你与之合拍的人，他们是否是一个你信任的好人，还是他们只是在给你提供确认，或者甚至是陪伴来对抗你的孤独感。因为孤独感也是一种会促使我们迅速产生依附的因素。伴侣、男朋友、女朋友、总而言之，爱是抵御孤独感的相当强大的保护因素；但如果我们把恋爱关系当成创可贴式的解决方案，或者用来填补某种情感空虚，
it's unlikely that we will be as rational and discerning about the people that we are seeking out. All they need to do is satisfy that baseline need of filling up our time and making us feel less alone for us to become bonded to them because we see them as providing something that we can't provide for ourselves. It's why I always say to people that you need to not date when you're feeling lonely or during major life transitions that might exacerbate loneliness, like right after a breakup or when you move to a new city. It will be difficult to determine whilst you're in that state whether you are pursuing this person for the right reasons or whether our innate need for attachment is driving you to confuse what that relationship really is. Is it a bond?
我们就很可能无法对我们所寻找的人保持理性和明辨。他们只需要满足填空的基本需求，让我们不那么孤独，我们就会与他们建立羁绊，因为我们把他们看作是提供了我们自己无法提供的东西。这就是为什么我总是对大家说，当你感到孤独时，或者在可能加剧孤独感的重大生活转变期间（比如刚分手后或搬到一个新城市时），你千万不要约会。处于这种状态下，你很难判断你追求这个人是为了正确的原因，还是我们与生俱来的依附需求在驱使你混淆这段关系的真正本质。这难道只是一种羁绊吗？
simply formed on the back of a perceived emotional deprivation. There's one more factor, I guess, tendency I want to mention that can create a lot of ambiguity between attachment and love. And it's one that comes up a fair bit, but I definitely think we need more research into it. Maybe it's a little bit controversial. Some people have theorized that being physically intimate with someone or having sex really early on
仅仅建立在感知到的情感剥夺的基础上？我想我还要提到最后一种因素，这种倾向会在依附和爱之间造成很多模糊不清。这是一个经常被提及的因素，但我绝对认为我们需要对此进行更多的研究。也许这有点争议。有些人推测，与某人发生亲密关系或很早就发生性行为
can disrupt our ability to make logical decisions about the longevity or the nature of a relationship. Sex is a bonding activity. It releases a high amount of oxytocin, and that produces feelings of connection and intimacy, even if it's not really there. You know, if you've only known each other for a few dates, that intimacy may cause a very biological attachment
会破坏我们对一段关系的持久性或本质做出理性决策的能力。性是一种能建立羁绊的活动。它会释放大量的催产素，即使这种亲密感并非真正存在，它也会产生连接和亲密感。你知道，如果你们只认识了几个约会，这种亲密感可能会导致一种非常生理上的依附
before a cognitive or a mental one, before you've actually gotten to know them. And I'm not saying this in like a Puritan fashion or advocating for, you know, no sex before marriage. But I think if you've noticed a habit of getting attached very quickly, maybe change up your approach to intimacy and sex before exclusivity. One of my friends has a three-date minimum, which I think works really well,
发生在认知或精神依附之前，发生在你真正了解他们之前。我这样说并不是出于清教徒式的态度，也不是在提倡诸如婚前无性行为之类的观点。但如果你发现自己有很快产生依附的习惯，也许可以改变一下在确立排他关系之前处理亲密关系和性行为的方式。我的一个朋友有一个“三次约会底线”，我觉得效果非常好，
or whatever standard you want to set for yourself so that all those hormones rushing through your body don't disrupt your decision-making. There's a few other tactics we can enlist to protect, ourselves and our heart in these situations to take our time and, you know, not just dive straight into a really intense attachment with someone. Firstly, you need to control your obsessive thoughts, as hard as that is by de-centering this person from your life until they prove they deserve to be there. When we frequently and obsessively think about a person, when we wonder whether they'll
或者设定任何你想为自己设立的标准，这样所有冲过你身体的荷尔蒙就不会扰乱你的决策。我们可以采取一些其他策略来保护自己和我们在这些情况下的心灵，放慢脚步，而不是直接一头扎进与某人的强烈依附中。首先，你需要控制你的强迫性想法，尽管这很难，方法是将这个人从你的生活中降权，直到他们证明自己配得上在那里。当我们频繁且强迫性地去想一个人，当我们想知道他们是否会
text us, find reasons to talk, speak about them continuously to our friends. what we're doing neurologically is strengthening the pathways associated with the image of this person and their presence in our lives. It's this idea called long-term potentiation, which is basically the opposite of if you don't use it, you lose it. If you use it too much, if you focus on something excessively, you train your brain to use those neural pathways more often and basically why are your brain in the short term, but also the long term, towards that person. In this way, your thought pattern becomes quite procedural, procedural meaning automatic, and you find that you can no longer control how often you're thinking of this person. You're exaggerating your level of attachment and
给我们发信息，寻找说话的理由，不断地对朋友提起他们。我们在神经学上所做的是，巩固了与这个人的形象以及他们在我们生活中的存在相关的神经通路。这被称为“长期增强作用”的概念，它基本上与“不用进废”（use it or lose it）相反。如果你过度使用它，如果你过度关注某事，你就是在训练你的大脑更频繁地使用这些神经通路，并在短期内、甚至长期内基本上将你的大脑朝着那个人的方向重塑。通过这种方式，你的思维模式变得相当程序化，“程序化”意味着自动化，你会发现你再也无法控制自己想念这个人的频率。你夸大了你的依附程度和
your infatuation. To deprogram yourself, you need to give your brain new experiences and interest to focus on. You need to enrich your life beyond this person's presence. And And that means making sure you prioritize your friends, taking on new hobbies, or even just small activities that give you joy, but also are a cause for reflection beyond your attachment to this person. Outdoor adventures, weeknight dinners with friends, a sporting class or a group. These are all great alternative to spending every single night with them. In those early stages of dating, I always have a two-day rule.
你的迷恋。为了对自己进行“重新编程”，你需要给你的大脑提供新的体验和感兴趣的事物来专注于它们。你需要丰富你的人生，超越这个人的存在。这意味着确保你优先考虑朋友，培养新的爱好，或者仅仅是那些能带给你快乐的小活动，同时它们也能引发你对超越对这个人的依附的反思。户外探险、与朋友的周中晚餐、运动课或团体活动。这些都是代替每晚与他们共度的绝佳替代方案。在约会初期，我总是遵循“两天规则”。
We can't see each other more than twice. a week because I know now that I really need and I want that time away from them to keep my independence and actually have some thinking time. And, you know, if you end up marrying this person, you know, seeing each other less at the beginning of your relationship isn't going to matter. It's actually just going to mean that you have that slow burn. Secondly, if you're quick to jump right in and perhaps create an unhealthy bond, force yourself to take things slow, particularly by managing your expectations. Try not to talk about the future with them unless they've given you a reason to
我们一周见面不能超过两次。因为我现在知道我真的需要并且想要一些远离他们的时间来保持我的独立性，并且真正拥有一些思考的时间。而且，你知道，如果你最后和这个人结婚了，你知道在关系初期少见面其实并不重要。它实际上只意味着你们之间的感情是细水长流的。其次，如果你很快就投入其中，并且可能建立了一种不健康的羁绊，强迫自己放慢脚步，特别是通过管理你的期望。尽量不要跟他们谈论未来，除非他们给了你理由
and crucially set emotional boundaries. I think when we crave closeness, especially during intense periods of loneliness, maybe after a breakup or something traumatic, and someone provides you with that opportunity, we know that oversharing and giving them very, very deep, a very deep idea of who we are is a great way to make them feel closer to you. And that can create what we know as a hyper dependency bond. The more you share, the more vulnerable you become, the quicker you're going to come to depend
并且至关重要的是要设定情感边界。我认为，当我们渴望亲密感，尤其是在经历强烈的孤独感时期（比如分手后或经历创伤之后），而某人为你提供了这种机会时，我们知道过度分享并让他们对我们有一个非常、非常深入、非常深刻的了解，是让他们觉得和你更亲近的好方法。而这会创造出我们所知的“过度依赖纽带”。你分享得越多，你变得越脆弱，你就会越快开始依赖
on this person and see them as someone you might love, not because of what they are, but because of what they offer you, which is a safe space to be validated. So I would say make sure you take your time and be clear about what you want and be discerning. I know that I would have saved myself a lot of pain and heartbreak if I'd been clearer with myself and others about what I actually wanted. And I'm thinking about someone in particular who I bonded to very quickly during a period of very intense stress and because of situations in my house and just general environment. So I began to rely on them really intensely and I got very attention.
这个人，并把他们看作是你可能爱的人，不是因为他们是什么样的人，而是因为他们能为你提供什么——一个可以获得认可的安全空间。所以我想说，确保你慢慢来，清楚自己想要什么，并且要有辨别力。我知道，如果我能对自己和他人更清楚地表达我真正想要什么，我本可以免去自己很多的痛苦和心碎。我想到了一个特定的人，在一段压力极大的时期，由于我家里的情况和一般环境，我和他建立羁绊的速度非常快。所以我开始非常强烈地依赖他，并且我变得很渴望关注，
attached very quickly, even when he told me that he wasn't looking for anything serious. You know, he was saying one thing and then acting another way, and I really chose to ignore what he was saying for the comfort of that closeness. Huge mistake, big mistake in those early stages before love develops. Whilst we're getting close, you really got to check on the reality of your situation every now and again, because attachment will form outside of your conscious control. and it's a natural precursor to something bigger, but that doesn't necessarily mean that you should be with this person.
非常快地产生了依附，甚至在他告诉我他不想找任何严肃关系的时候也是如此。你知道，他嘴上说一套，行为却是另一套，而为了那种亲密感带来的慰藉，我真的选择忽视了他所说的话。大错特错，在爱发展起来之前的早期阶段，这是一个巨大的错误。在我们变得亲密的同时，你确实必须时不时地审视你现实中的处境，因为依附会在你的意识控制之外形成。
If you've found yourself in this position right now, wondering, do I really love for this person? Are they really my future? Or have I just, you know, become attached to them? There's also a series of questions that I think are important to ask yourself. I've found these to be so incredibly discerning and truth revealing in my own dating life to ensure that I'm not just rushing into things because of an emotional urge or human nature. Firstly, when you think about how they make you feel,
它是更宏大事物的一个自然先兆，但这并不一定意味着你应该和这个人在一起。如果你现在发现自己处于这种境地，心里在想：“我真的爱这个人吗？他们真的是我的未来吗？还是我只是……你知道的，对他们产生了依附？”我认为还有一系列问题是问问自己很重要的。在我的约会生活中，我发现这些问题极具辨别力且能揭示真相，它们能确保我不会仅仅因为一种情感冲动或人性而仓促行事。首先，当你思考他们带给你的感受时，
do you think about physical elements of the relationship or the quality of your emotional bond? Would you be just as happy being in bed with them as you would be having a long, deep conversation? Secondly, do you genuinely care about this person's happiness and well-being, even if it means making sacrifices or compromises. Could someone else be in their place right now and would you feel the same way? This is really important because it highlights the distinction between wanting basic companionship and actually feeling a genuine deep connection based on their individual qualities. Have you imagined a future with this person?
你想的是这段关系的身体层面还是你们情感纽带的质量？与他们同床共枕，会让你像进行一次长时间的深度对话一样快乐吗？其次，你是否真心关心这个人的幸福和福祉，哪怕这意味着要做出牺牲或妥协。此时此刻，如果换作别人站在他们的位置上，你会有同样的感受吗？这一点真的很重要，因为它突显了渴望基本陪伴与实际感受到基于他们个人特质的真挚深厚连接之间的区别。你想象过和这个人有未来吗？
Do you have shared goals, dreams? Do you have plans for the future? Are you willing to work through conflicts and communicate openly rather than just avoiding difficult conversations? And what do you feel when you're around them? Also, what do you feel when you're not around them? Is it calm? Do you know that you'll see them again soon?
你们有共同的目标、梦想吗？你们有对未来的规划吗？你们愿意共同克服冲突并进行公开沟通，而不是只知道逃避艰难的对话吗？当你和他们在一起时，你的感受是什么？还有，当你不在他们身边时，你的感受是什么？是平静吗？你知道你很快就会再见到他们吗？
Is it peace or are you anxious? Are you fretful? Are you unsure of what you want? You know what that sounds a lot like? It sounds a lot like they are activating an abandonment wound. or an anxious attachment and I think it's important to be honest with yourself about whether beginning this way is going to actually lead to a good foundation for a future together. You know, remember love is calm, love is peaceful, you can still be excited and passionate,
是平静还是焦虑？你是心神不宁吗？你不确定自己想要什么吗？你知道这听起来像什么吗？这听起来很像是他们在触发你的“被抛弃创伤”
but you don't have to worry about how they feel. You know, attachment is a lot more nuanced and I guess fickle, it comes quicker, it burns brighter, it feels nice, but these two things are not the same and confusing them can create a lot of havoc but also regret later on when you realize you are perhaps mistaken and you can't trust yourself anymore. So I hope that this has given you a good guide, a good ability to discern between these two feelings. Also, I would say if you are listening to this podcast with a particular person in mind, I think that just that fact that you have, that you're having those questions about am I in love or am I just attached?
或者是焦虑型依附，我认为对自己诚实是很重要的，要看以这种方式开始是否真的能为未来的共同生活打下良好的基础。你知道，记住，爱是平静的，爱是安宁的，你依然可以感到兴奋和充满激情，
Might be indicating that you are just attached because I think love sometimes comes without questions. Like you kind of know. And that's something that I haven't really, I didn't really realize until recently. But when they're making you feel uncomfortable, they're inconsistent, that's not love. That's, they don't love you. If they're doing that to you, they don't love you. I know it's a very hard truth.
但你不必担心他们的感受。你知道，依附要微妙得多，我猜也更反复无常，它来得更快，燃烧得更烈，感觉很好，但这这两者并不相同，把它们混淆会在以后造成很多混乱，也会带来很多遗憾，当你意识到自己可能弄错了，而且再也无法信任自己时。所以我希望这能给你提供一个好的指南，让你有能力辨别这两种感觉。另外，我想说，如果你在听这个播客时心里想着某个特定的人，我认为仅仅因为你有这些疑问——“我是陷入爱河了，还是只是产生了依附？”
I feel kind of guilty for saying it so harshly. but I also think it's important to note. So I hope this episode has been enlightening. I hope it has helped you. It was very, very interesting to record and to talk about. It kind of just spilled out of me. This has been on my mind for so long. As always, if there is someone in your life who needs to hear this,
可能就暗示了你只是产生了依附，因为我认为爱有时是不需要疑问的。就像你心里自然会知道。这也是我直到最近才真正意识到的一点。但当他们让你感到不舒服、对你忽冷忽热时，那不是爱。那是，他们不爱你。如果他们这样对你，他们就不爱你。我知道这是一个很难接受的真相。
please feel free to send it to them. You never know who it's going to help out. And also, if you feel cool to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now, and follow us along at that psychology podcast to see behind the scenes stuff, video content to keep up to date with what's going on. We would love to see you over there. As always, thank you for listening to today's episode. I hope you are in love. And if you're attached, I hope that this has helped you figure out why that might be. And
我因为说得这么刺耳而感到有些内疚。但我同时也认为这一点值得指出。所以我希望这一集能给你带来启发。我希望它对你有所帮助。录制和谈论这一集非常非常有趣。它就像是从我心底倾泻而出。这件事压在我心头太久了。一如既往，如果你的生活中有人需要听到这些，
as always, we will see you back next week for another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
请随时分享给他们。你永远不知道它会帮助到谁。另外，如果你觉得可以的话，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，并在That Psychology Podcast关注我们，了解幕后花絮和视频内容，跟进最新动态。我们很希望能在那边见到你。一如既往，感谢收听今天的节目。我希望你正沐浴爱河。如果你只是产生了依附，我希望这能帮你弄清楚原因。并且
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
一如既往，我们下周同一时间再见，收听另一集节目。嘿，各位好！欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在iHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令两名女子怀上双胞胎。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“欧文斯女士，这份特定的检测报告是你篡改了两次，对吧？”“我篡改了一次检测报告。”网络侦探们倾巢而出，才揭露出了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子彻底炸了。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. And you will come out. on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱如陷阱》播客。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦。你就会蜕变成
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。